hoy se conmemora el día contra la
violencia y el acoso escolar incluido el
ciberacoso que son frecuentes y afectan
a niños y adolescentes los estados
miembros de la unesco detectaron el
primer jueves de noviembre de cada año
para darle visibilidad a esta
problemática reconociendo de este modo
que la violencia en el entorno escolar
bajo todas sus formas atenta contra los
derechos de los niños y también los
adolescentes la salud y el bienestar
para ello quiero saludar entonces en
nuestra primera invitada del día ya
sandra vinocur licenciada en
psicopedagogía
miembro del equipo de investigación del
proyecto ubacyt violencia
estigmatización y condición estudiantil
gracias andra por estar aquí con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
primero para poner en contexto no para
después seguir analizando todas las
aristas que tiene este tema tan
interesante que se considera como acoso
escolar o ciberacoso
buenos días primero
el acoso escolar es la situación en
donde niños o niñas están siendo
molestados de manera
[Música]
de manera complicada en el sentido de
que hay una complicidad
entre varios y un silencio
de los espectadores que saben que hay un
niño que está siendo molestado que está
siendo
hostigado de manera conjunta digamos
diferenciamos lo que es el acoso escolar
como una situación de complicidad grupal
de ciertas situaciones en donde puede
haber un chiste que moleste a otro como
que son situaciones diferentes porque la
grupal y dady el silencio y la
complicidad grupal le da una potencia al
acoso que hace que sea muy difícil
destrabar lo de desarmarlo porque hay
una complicidad silenciosa de los
espectadores entonces lo primero es
diferenciar la situación es de molestar
a alguien con lo que es realmente una
complicidad grupal y un silencio en
encontrar un uno o varios niños para
hacer
hostigados si en dónde bueno como decía
los espectadores tienen una función muy
importante diferenciar primero estas dos
figuras y ahí bueno y trabajo
esencialmente tiene que ver con poder
poner en palabras poder desarmar el
conflicto poder hacer que circulen las
diferencias en el sentido de entender
que todos somos diferentes y que las
diferencias forman parte de la vida y
forman parte de lo que es
la variedad y que enriquece a los grupos
saldrá si le quiero le quiero preguntar
las consecuencias que un acoso trae para
el desarrollo de un niño en la etapa
pues digamos de la niñez y la
adolescencia cuando está cuando sale del
colegio cuáles son las consecuencias más
que usted resalta más no de esta
problemática
pero la consecuencia sentirse por fuera
sentirse diferente y eso trae angustia
no y bueno uno no podría
anticipar en el futuro cuáles serían
todo depende como se transite y con la
esperanza de poder trabajar lo digamos
situaciones de acoso se presentan no es
que uno va a evitar que sucedan lo que
no tiene que hacer es trabajar para que
esto disminuya y realmente poder
desarmar esas situaciones para que los
niños y las niñas estén lo mejor posible
en las instituciones escolares y en la
vida no pero
consecuencias anticipadas depende
también de cómo lo transita cada uno y
de las herramientas que uno pueda
construir con los niños que están siendo
acosados también para fortalecerse y
salir de esas situaciones y ahí tanto la
escuela como la familia tienen mucha
injerencia digamos hay que trabajar
también con los papás ahí de como
reubicar algunas cuestiones de cómo
repensar algunas cuestiones si sandra se
habla también mucho digamos de los niños
acosados pero no se habla del acosador
porque muchas veces estos niños es que
acosan vienen de familias problemáticas
es donde pues donde ven violencia en su
familia y trasladan de alguna manera eso
a su entorno no digamos en el colegio es
que se puede hacer para evitar que haya
menos acosadores
y cómo se trabaja con el niño que hace
bullying
bueno se trabaja individualmente se
trabaja también con los papás hay
digamos situaciones de violencias a
veces en las casas
que uno tiene que poder abordar desde
cuando trabaja en instituciones
educativas
para poder hacer consciente porque
muchas veces las violencias en las casas
no son conscientes es como la forma
natural de comunicación entonces
requiere todo un trabajo y una
concientización de este modo de
vincularse que afecta la vida de estos
niños que acosan a otros no pero vuelvo
a decir son niños que acosan a otros que
además consiguen complicidad de su
entorno si no son solos digamos hay un
grupo que se constituye y que participa
de esta situación de acoso
sandra digamos que en esta época de
pandemia de kobe 19 sobre todo a lo
mejor cuando estuvimos todos en
confinamiento al principio de esta
pandemia se incrementó el ciberacoso
como se comportó este fenómeno
hubo más ciberacoso porque los chicos
tuvieron más acceso a
las computadoras a las tabletas a todo
lo que es comunicación a través de las
pantallas
pero no diría que fue
mucho más
virulento que lo que sucede
en la cotidianeidad digamos los chicos
acceden a las pantallas sin supervisión
es de los adultos
y en el momento del confinamiento el
adulto estaba más cerca sí entonces
había como más vigilancia en relación a
lo que sucedía en las pantallas por la
situación de encierro que cuando los
papás están trabajando o las mamás están
trabajando y los chicos están solos en
las pantallas